as one of the breakthrough young stars
of the Harry Potter film franchise tom
Felton grew up in front of the whole
world right alongside his character the
villainous Draco Malfoy he may not have
been a member of the heroic Trinity in
the series but among potter fans
Felton's name became just about as
well-known as his co-stars so it seemed
logical that he'd be among those who'd
slither into the a-list after the series
came to an end in 2011 unlike some of
the others though Felton has since
struggled to shed his status as an
alumnus of Hogwarts which means his
career outside of the world of
Witchcraft and Wizardry has been
anything but magical where his Daniel
Radcliffe has become something of an
indie sensation and Emma Watson
headlined an entirely different
blockbuster with curses and castles tom
Felton hasn't been able to ride his
Nimbus 2000 to the top of the Hollywood
ladder just yet let's take a look at
some of the reasons Hollywood won't cast
him any more conflicted feelings
starring in an eighth film mega movie
franchise might seem like the
opportunity of a lifetime for any actor
but tom Felton didn't cherish the
experience of being an overnight
cinematic success story as much as
others might before the final film
Deathly Hallows part-2 hit theaters he
told the Daily Mail that he looked
forward to the freedom of not starring
in the film's anymore saying one thing
that people keep on saying to me is that
the wealth and the fame must have made
up for missing out on my childhood but
the idea of money putting a price on
your childhood is ridiculous to me Fame
is not a positive thing the idea of
being famous is a lot better than the
reality it's fantastic when you go to
premieres and people cheer you but it's
not real considering most of those fans
who were cheering him on at those
various premieres were the ones he'd
need to see his next movies those words
may have come back to bite him harder
than Nagini
a career left turn after Harry Potter
Daniel Radcliffe decided to give the
Broadway circuit in small budget films a
whirl and Emma Watson went to college
became a beauty brand ambassador and
left Hermione behind with films like
this as the end meanwhile Tom Felton's
first big post Potter move was to wrap
yes wrap in 2011 felt and revealed that
he'd scored a recording deal with an
independent label to produce some hip
hop music saying I was thinking of doing
some in dub style stuff I'm looking to
get into the grime rap UK scene Felton
added that he intended to change his
image and although that public persona
overhauled
seemed to pan out some of his music has
made way to the public sphere
however despite a few EP releases and a
moderate amount of viral attention on
YouTube his music has hardly been
successful enough to qualify as a new
career path to familiar his MC effort
might have at least been a change of
pace but Felton's next big screen
adventure was far too familiar to his
harry potter persona Felton claims he's
not at all like the kid that made him
famous two villains with you I am very
on Malfoy like in my day-to-day biddings
however in 2011 s Rise of the Planet of
the Apes he played a small part as Dodge
Landon a cruel zoo security guard who
tortures the film's central sentient ape
Caesar like Draco the character is
remarkable only for his sniveling
demeanor in the ease with which
audiences root against him between this
role and his villainous TV turn on TNT's
murder in the first he may not be
distancing himself from the role that
made him famous which could make him
seem a little OneNote - casting
directors indeed even Radcliffe has had
to work hard to extricate himself from
the world of broomsticks and flu powder
taking roles that are far off the mark
of the Boy Who Lived
by heading right back into an unlikable
mini baddie role after Deathly Hallows
Felton may have made a huge career
misstep right from the start regaining
confidence another surprising downside
to the safety of a long-lived role like
Felton had in the Harry Potter series is
that the series in can feel a little
like being thrown into the ocean without
a life vest the actor has admitted that
returning to the regular practice of
auditioning for parts to sustain a
lifestyle rather than just trying to
fill in the blanks between sequels was
very difficult for him to adjust to he
told the Daily Mail in 2011 I'm much
more nervous in auditions now than I was
at 11 you take a lot of hits before you
get something good the first few were
heartbreaking the disappointment of
being denied certain roles was so
disorienting for him in fact that he
considered walking away from the
business altogether saying I thought I
can't do this they are cutthroat in
America before you even started
someone's playing on the blackberry
you're reading your lines physically
convulsing and they just say thank you
that means get lost I did 19 auditions
and got the 20th for the film the
apparition to make matters worse that
movie would mark the start of a series
of box-office flops missing box-office
man
although the Harry Potter series was a
box-office phenomenon Felton has still
not proven himself to be a bankable
actor his small-time thriller picked the
apparition failed to recoup its
financier investment despite having both
a Harry Potter star and Twilight alum
Ashley Greene leading the cast since
then he's yet to appear in a film that
made any kind of impression at the
ticket booth even movies that have been
relatively well received by critics like
the Regal biopic Bell and a United
Kingdom featured him only in supporting
roles and brought in very little money
during their small theatrical runs
Felton's not the only one of the harry
potter alums who has struggled to
convince muggles to see his movies but
being associated with so many bombs
likely isn't making his new agents job
any easier Blonde Ambition considering
his dismal box-office streak Tom
Felton's chances of nabbing a leading
movie role anytime soon seem low but it
might not be a good idea to tell him
that in fact the actors ambitions seemed
to be unfettered he not only wants
another franchise but he wants one of
the most iconic and long-lasting of all
time bond James Bond he told Metro that
playing the suave double-oh-seven agent
is an unfulfilled career ambition for
him adding I haven't landed James Bond
yet plain bond or a Bond villain was why
I wanted to do movies in the first place
considering that maybe the most coveted
role in all of Hollywood his
expectations may be a bit lofty and
unrealistic
time to turn it around these days tom
Felton does seem to be settling in with
a more low-key professional life style
in 2016 for example he nabbed a
recurring role in the third season of
The CW's the flash and while the role
didn't carry on to the next season it
did help introduce him to a new and
different fanbase in the comics
community he was also cast in the little
scene but ambitious adaptation of
William Shakespeare's Hamlet titled Oh
fie Leah
alongside some big names like Daisy
Ridley and Naomi Watts
neither project has put him on a new
trajectory for success yet but they have
helped felt and stretch into new
territory that might better convince
casting agents he's capable of doing
more than a bunch of Draco Malfoy
impressions in the future thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]